You want to change the world,
you start from yourself and work outward
because you build your competence that
way.
So like I don't know how you can go out
and protest the structure of the entire
economic system if can't keep your room
organized.
People try to change the outside world
for lots of ways,
but many of those ways aren't just pure
good.
And so what I've thought about is that,
well what you start to do is you start
to tail and act out the truth locally,
like within the domain of your actual
competence.
You know,
cause the world presents itself as a
series of puzzles,
some of which your capable of solving
and some of which you're not.
And you have many puzzles in front of
you that you could solve,
but you choose not to.
You know that those are the things that
weigh on your conscience.
It's like,
you know why I should really do this,
but you don't.
It's like,
so I had this idea a long time ago
because the world is a pretty dreadful
place.
I thought,
well,
what would the world be like if people
stopped avoiding the things they knew
they should do?
You know?
Because the question is how much are we
contributing to the fact that life is a,
is an existential catastrophe and a
tragedy?
How much is our own corruption
contributing to that?
That's a really worthwhile question.
Things you leave undone because you're
angry,
you're resentful,
you're lazy,
you have a neuro Shia,
well you consult your conscience and it
says,
well,
you know,
that place over there,
it could use a little work.
It's the same as working on yourself.
And so you clean that up because he can
and then things are a little clearer
around you and you're a little better
off because you've practiced a bit and
and so your little stronger.
And then something else manifest itself
and says,
well maybe you could like take a crack
at fixing me up too.
So he decided to do that and then that
gets a little bit more pristine,
you know,
and soon.
And it's humble because you're not
exceeding your domain of competence.
You know,
it's like,
don't be fixing up the economy.
18 year old.
Can you even clean up your own room?
No.
Well,
you should think about that.
You should think about that because if
you can't even clean up your own room,
who the hell are you to give advice to
the world?